[ __ ] Santa thank you have you been a
long wait yeah I've been learning a lot
now
I wish killed my Atman is amazing I
loved it it was actually so funny I love
twisting that was Lisa cute I went go in
rural too much don't worry good how long
does it take for you to perfect the West
Virginia accent uh I don't know if I did
I don't know if I actually ever achieved
that boy's face don't thank you it was
like splitting hairs so if I wasn't
really careful I would fall I would slip
into the Alabama and Mississippi thing
and then but we had somebody in my ear
and I watched a ton of this documentary
if you ever want to see a good
documentary on West Virginia look up the
wild and wonderful whites of West
Virginia oh yeah it's really really good
taking I love a good book which is
incredible actually
crazy dog what was it like working with
Daniel Craig cause yeah I thought he was
and Daniel Craig
it looked he's asked please oh okay I'm
kidding he didn't no no no man I like it
is a complete ku that we that we got him
in this movie I mean yeah I thought he
was sorry like surprised like I wasn't
expecting to be able to meet her own I
know anyway well I think I hadn't seen
his early stuff before just bonded but I
don't think a lot of people in America
have you know I think maybe they they
probably wouldn't even have known if
they've seen him in a way but it the
guys like I mean the key can do anything
first off in life and and just and in
the theatrical world yeah but I I
couldn't believe that we got him for Joe
banging I mean it's Joanie was my
favorite character in the movie and I
think we just got really lucky that he
was that coming out of this like Bond
marathon I love life and and then he
just really wanted to do something so
completely unbond and pretty far since
we're in an unusual setting abajo we
need to play a little game
so um why dissociation and if you're any
good at back I'm not that good okay wait
a min exactly where that refers they're
always associated with oh man my brain
associates very oddly so you're going to
get you're going to get
like you're gonna get horrible horrible
answers that aren't going to make any
sense but I just need okay don't move on
with it okay so the first one is
cauliflower belly button back body part
body part yeah peanut thanks feet light
switch swimming I'm just gonna crow
black flash okay
oh I don't have that okay I gotta go
again light bulb filament - and bright
pastel green looks and summer peaches
for trekkers uh what's trick it checkers
oh oh the other chest and two out um
fashion trend pinochle I don't affect
the game I'm gonna go with and ceiling
old people here all people have a
greater okay it's a lot especially
sabelli shoelaces ready trainer because
arm pit glory um hygiene
[Laughter]
tea time and drinks uh your smile um
happy hey to them oh that was fun thank
you so much thank you thank you